56 year old was attacked and killed on
sunday
while riding her bike in the east valley
tonight friends and family held a vigil
near the intersection where it happened
to honor her life
they say it was larger than they ever
could have imagined sasha loftis joining
us now live near hollywood and sahara
with more
denise and brian what started as a chat
between friends turned into a powerful
image of sadness and support tonight
this memorial is just one way so many
are
showing their love for the woman they
called shelly
there's certain people in this world
that people
cannot find a negative word for she'd be
one flowers
candles and handwritten messages serve
as a symbol
of heartbreak she's very close to being
perfect i know there's nobody that's
perfect but
she was pretty perfect as those who
loved michelle weisman
gathered here thursday to honor a woman
they call
absolutely wonderful and it was so
senseless what happened and
she was just senseless the 56 year old
was killed on her bicycle
along hollywood boulevard sunday when
police say
a minivan passenger leaned out the
window and intentionally pushed her
she wouldn't want us to be angry and she
wouldn't want us
for revenge she just wants us to move on
and be better people
but those who knew michelle best don't
want to focus on her death
but instead choose to highlight her rich
life
we did not expect this outcome this just
started as a small chat group
and it just snowballed into a lot more
and
i'm proud they say this considerable
crowd
represents the marks she made and that's
probably the only positive
to this is the people coming together in
a world
that will never forget her we're going
to get through this
we're going to get through this for her
the man who police say leaned out of the
minivan's passenger side to push
michelle fell from the window and also
died on sunday
the driver who was driving that car at
the time
his face airs in police custody rather
facing multiple charges
including open murder for now reporting
live in the east valley sasha loftis
8 news now